harrisburg is the capital of
pennsylvania and it's one of the brokest
cities in america the municipal
government has so much debt last year it
attempted to file for bankruptcy there
isn't much of a 1% to help Harrisburg
pay its debt a third of its residents
live below the poverty line and its
population has been gradually shrinking
Harrisburg has declined presents an
extreme case of what's happened in
municipalities across the country it's a
cautionary tale of how the ambitions of
a charismatic mayor can destroy a city
[Music]
American cities are drowning in debt
thanks to a spending binge that took off
in the mid 90s local governments owned
more than two point eight trillion
dollars and many lack the means to make
good on those obligations Harrisburg is
one of a handful of cities that have
effectively gone bankrupt and many more
are expected to follow suit reckless
spending did more than ruin Harrisburg's
balance sheet it undermined the city's
economy and purpose steven Russell Reed
who declined to be interviewed for this
story was mayor of the city for 28 years
and he bears most of the responsibility
for Harrisburg's nightmare if what
happened in Harrisburg happened to our
country we would clearly call it a
dictatorship Jason Smith is a designer
and small business owner who ran for
mayor against Reid in 2005 you can't
have an authentic public process when
money is moving around without oversight
and being spent on things that no one
wants I don't see anything wrong with
government being entrepreneurial Randi
King was mayor Reid's communications
director for 18 years we have to
understand the circumstance in the early
1980s Harrisburg was dead there was no
businesses downtown its population had
declined by more than half in the past
20 years
he believed differently about Harrisburg
and about cities in general he believed
that's a responsibility of the
leadership of the community to step in
and do things occasionally when there's
a need
sector isn't addressing many cities
spend taxpayer money subsidizing sports
arenas Harrisburg outre built a baseball
stadium and then it also bought the team
that plays there to prevent it from
moving to Springfield Massachusetts many
cities subsidize hotels and convention
centers Harrisburg outre bought a hotel
to keep it from shutting down many
cities subsidized museums and cultural
institutions mayor Reed wanted to build
his own museums which he believed would
transform Harrisburg into a tourist
mecca much as Washington DC and its many
museums draws millions of people to the
city each year or New York City
that's what Steve Reid's vision for
Harrisburg was read conceived of a
museum all that life on the frontier so
we headed west to start buying artifacts
he bought a stagecoach a Gatling gun
canned goods badges boots so you have
all that together in one town wow you
are a nationally scaled national class
tourism attraction but a warship from
the war of 1812 it was burned and sunk
but he got the embers anyway we always
used to joke you know sell Annie
Oakley's Underpants the museum plan was
ultimately shot down today most of
Reed's collection is sitting in a
warehouse it would have been a big hit
I'm really sorry that that never
manifested the mayor's dream of a
national civil war museum did become a
reality but in a way that would have
disappointed Honest Abe we'd spent more
than 16 million dollars in city money
acquiring the collection when that
wasn't enough he took money from the
Harrisburg Authority a branch of local
government that's responsible for
maintaining the city's waste in water
systems think he learned early on that
it's possible to borrow money for one
thing and move the money into funds no
one's heard of to get blank checks to
buy whatever you want
the mayor often lacked scruples when
spending those blank checks Harrisburg
borrowed 3.7 million dollars to help
build this office complex for a printing
company the project went awry when the
developer was indicted for embezzlement
Harrisburg's incinerator debacle was its
best-known and costliest venture the
incinerator which was built in the early
70s was a lemon from the very beginning
he hired an incompetent contractor to
renovate the plant and then neglected to
get insurance on the job today the city
owes 310 million dollars on the
incinerator that's a little more than
half Harrisburg's total liabilities
which add up to six hundred and ten
million according to the city controller
although nobody knows the exact figure
since Harrisburg is four years behind in
completing its financial statements
Harrisburg like many American cities was
so preoccupied with building white
elephants that it neglected core
functions like education and public
safety Harrisburg on a per capita basis
is one of the most violent cities in
Pennsylvania Matt bruit is the president
of the Commonwealth Foundation a
libertarian think-tank in Harrisburg
those who can live outside of the city
are certainly choosing to do so and
we've seen that with the population
shifts this is not a place to raise a
family about 60% of harrisburg students
are failing
according to Pennsylvania's statewide
achievement tests mayor Reed address
this problem by pouring money into
school construction the Harrisburg
school district is racked up two hundred
and seventy million dollars in debt
which is about two and a half times
Pennsylvania's average school debt per
capita everyone agrees the schools look
great they may not have books the
weightlifting room may not have weights
and the students might be the worst
performing in the state if not the
nation but the buildings are beautiful
failing schools were a major factor in
driving Harrisburg's middle class to the
suburbs
my family left Harrisburg two years ago
we decided we could go somewhere where
there's a good school district and
property taxes will be lower I have a
number of friends who are now trapped in
the city they can't sell their houses
and they simply can't leave the
revitalization of the city wasn't going
to be done at least in a sustainable
manner through political force it's
going to have to be a change that comes
because you've created a climate that is
welcoming families welcoming businesses
and until you have a mayor and a city
council that recognizes their job isn't
job creation their job is getting better
schools better crime all those things
will contribute to the quality of life
Harrisburg stack space is so depleted
there's no way it can make good on its
debt
ultimately state and county taxpayers
will bear the burden of Harrisburg's
recklessness an economic mess is coming
to an ugly end and that is a wonderful
step forward for Harrisburg I know that
sounds terrible but we can't live in
delusion forever and at some point you
got to say what is the reality people
are going to be great empowered to say
okay well it's not as rosy as we thought
it was but here's what it is what are we
going to do with it